12 men commit suicide every day in Great  Britain one of them was any robbers who  left behind his friends and family his  brother-in-law professional British  rugby player Luke amber had no clue and  he was suicidal that's why i sat at the  hashtag it's okay to talk when undertook  his life we decided early 102 statistic  and what to use the payroll info to  clock out not half of your families and  friends answer for them  you  huge tell someone that you're feeling  depressed are you feeling down typical  thing would be I'll get on with it girl  be soft come on you make your mum and  that's what we'll try it down  you  this sign is it is a true sunny you are  always welcome to talk you don't have to  feel stigma doctors feel unwelcome you  don't have to feel judged speak your  mind and make sure people hear you  he's not one to hold open it that's not  what Monday's Manley's been able to  express your feelings gonna get out  there and break down these barriers  horse